I never graduated from college and this
is the closest I've ever gotten to a
college graduation today I want to tell
you three stories from my life that's it
the first story is about connecting the
dots I dropped out of Reed College after
the first six months but then stayed
around as a drop-in for another 18
months or so before I really quit so
why'd I drop out it started before I was
born my biological mother was a young
unwed graduate student and she decided
to put me up for adoption she felt very
strongly that I should be adopted by
college graduates so everything was all
set for me to be adopted at Birth by a
lawyer and his wife except that when I
popped out they decided at the last
minute that they really wanted a girl so
my parents who were on a waiting list
got a call in the middle of the night
asking we've got an unexpected baby boy
do you want him they said horse my
biological mother found out later that
my mother had never graduated from
college and that my father had never
graduated from high school she refused
to sign the final adoption papers she
only relented a few months later when my
parents promised that I would go to
college this was the start in my life
and 17 years later I did go to college
but I naively chose a college that was
almost as expensive as Stanford
and all of my working-class parent
savings were being spent on my college
tuition
after six months I couldn't see the
value in it I had no idea what I wanted
to do with my life and no idea how
College was going to help me figure it
out
and here I was spending all the money my
parents had saved their entire life
so I decided to drop out and trust that
it would all work out okay
it was pretty scary at the time but
looking back it was one of the best
decisions I ever made
the minute I dropped out
I could stop taking the required classes
that didn't interest me and begin
dropping in on the ones that looked far
more interesting
it wasn't all romantic I didn't have a
dorm room so I slept on the floor in
friends rooms
I returned Coke bottles for the five
cent deposits to buy food with
and I would walk the seven miles across
town every Sunday night
to get one good meal a week at the Hari
Krishna Temple
I loved it
and much of what I stumbled into by
following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be Priceless later on
let me give you one example
read college at that time offered
perhaps the best calligraphy instruction
in the country throughout the campus
every poster every label on every drawer
was beautifully hand calligraphed
because I had dropped out and didn't
have to take the normal classes
I decided to take a calligraphy class to
learn how to do this
I learned about serif and sans-serif
typefaces about varying the amount of
space between different letter
combinations about what makes great
typography great
it was beautiful historical artistically
subtle in a way that science can't
capture
and I found it fascinating
none of this had even a hope of any
practical application in my life
but ten years later when we were
designing the first Macintosh computer
it all came back to me and we designed
it all into the Mac it was the first
computer with beautiful typography
if I had never dropped in on that single
course in college the Mac would have
never had multiple typefaces or
proportionally spaced fonts and since
Windows just copied the Mac it's likely
that no personal computer would have
them
[Applause]
if I had never dropped out I would have
never dropped in on that calligraphy
class and personal computers might not
have the wonderful typography that they
do
of course it was impossible to connect
the dots looking forward when I was in
college but it was very very clear
looking backwards 10 years later
again you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards
so you have to trust that the dots will
somehow connect in your future you have
to trust in something your gut Destiny
Life Karma whatever
because believing that the dots will
connect down the road will give you the
confidence to follow your heart even
when it leads you off the well-worn path
and that will make all the difference my
second story is about love and loss
I was lucky I found what I love to do
early in life was and I started Apple in
my parents garage when I was 20. we
worked hard and in 10 years Apple had
grown from Just the Two of Us in a
garage into a two billion dollar company
with over four thousand employees we
just released our finest creation the
Macintosh a year earlier and I just
turned 30.
and then I got fired
how can you get fired from a company you
started
well as Apple grew we hired someone who
I thought was very talented to run the
company with me and for the first year
or so things went well but then our
visions of the future began to diverge
and eventually we had a falling out
when we did our board of directors sided
with him and so at 30 I was out and very
publicly out
what had been the focus of my entire
adult life was gone and it was
devastating
I really didn't know what to do for a
few months
I felt that I'd let the previous
generation of entrepreneurs down that I
had dropped the Baton as it was being
passed to me
I met with David Packard and Bob Noyes
and tried to apologize for screwing up
so badly
I was a very public failure and I even
thought about running away from the
valley
but something slowly began to dawn on me
I still loved what I did
the turn of events at Apple had not
changed that one bit
I'd been rejected but I was still in
love
and so I decided to start over
I didn't see it then but it turned out
that getting fired from Apple was the
best thing that could have ever happened
to me
the heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner again less sure about
everything
it freed me to enter one of the most
creative periods of my life
during the next five years I started a
company named next another company named
Pixar and fell in love with an amazing
woman who would become my wife
Pixar went on to create the world's
first computer animated feature film Toy
Story and is now the most successful
Animation Studio in the world
in a remarkable turn of events Apple
bought next and I returned to Apple and
the technology we developed at next is
at the heart of Apple's current
Renaissance
and Laureen and I have a wonderful
family together
I'm pretty sure none of this would have
happened if I hadn't been fired from
Apple
it was awful tasting medicine but I
guess the patient needed it
sometimes life sometimes life's going to
hit you in the head with a brick don't
lose faith
I'm convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that I loved what I
did you've got to find what you love and
that is as true for work as it is for
your lovers
your work is going to fill a large part
of your life and the only way to be
truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great work and the only way
to do great work is to love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't settle as with all matters of
the heart you'll know when you find it
and like any great relationship it just
gets better and better as the years roll
on so keep looking don't settle
[Applause]
[Music]
my third story is about death
when I was 17 I read a quote that went
something like if you live each day as
if it was your last someday you'll most
certainly be right
it made an impression on me and since
then for the past 33 years I've looked
in the mirror every morning and asked
myself if today were the last day of my
life what I want to do what I am about
to do today
and whenever the answer has been no for
too many days in a row I know I need to
change something
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life
because almost everything all external
expectations all Pride all fear of
embarrassment or failure these things
just fall away in the face of death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the Trap of
thinking you have something to lose you
are already naked there is no reason not
to follow your heart
about a year ago I was diagnosed with
cancer
I had a scan at 7 30 in the morning and
it clearly showed a tumor on my pancreas
I didn't even know what a pancreas was
the doctors told me this was almost
certainly a type of cancer that is
incurable and that I should expect to
live no longer than three to six months
my doctor advised me to go home and get
my Affairs in order which is doctor's
code for prepare to die
it means to try and tell your kids
everything
you thought you'd have the next 10 years
to tell them in just a few months
it means to make sure everything is
buttoned up so that it will be as easy
as possible for your family
it means to say your goodbyes
I live with that diagnosis all day
later that evening I had a biopsy where
they stuck an endoscope down my throat
through my stomach and into my
intestines put a needle into my pancreas
and got a few cells from the tumor
I was sedated but my wife who was there
told me that when they viewed the cells
under a microscope the doctors started
crying because it turned out to be a
very rare form of pancreatic cancer that
is curable with surgery I had the
surgery and thankfully I'm fine now
this was the closest I've been to facing
death and I hope it's the closest I get
for a few more decades having lived
through it I can now say this to you
with a bit more certainty than when
death was a useful but purely
intellectual concept
no one wants to die
even people who want to go to heaven
don't want to die to get there
and yet
at this destination we all share
no one has ever escaped it and that is
as it should be because death is very
likely the single best invention of life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new
right now the new is you
but someday not too long from now you
will gradually become the old and be
cleared away
sorry to be so dramatic but it's quite
true
your time is limited so don't waste it
living someone else's life
don't be trapped by Dogma which is
living with the results of other
people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become
everything else is secondary
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there was an amazing publication called
the whole earth catalog which was one of
the Bibles of my generation
it was created by a fellow named Stuart
brand not far from here in Menlo Park
and he brought it to life with his
poetic touch
this was in the late 60s before personal
computers and desktop publishing so it
was all made with typewriters scissors
and Polaroid cameras it was sort of like
Google and paperback form 35 years
before Google came along
it was idealistic overflowing with neat
tools and great Notions
Stewart and his team put out several
issues of the whole earth catalog and
then when it had run its course they put
out a final issue it was the mid-1970s
and I was your age
on the back cover of their final issue
was a photograph of an early morning
Country Road the kind you might find
yourself hitchhiking on if you were so
adventurous
beneath it were the words stay hungry
stay foolish it was their farewell
message as they signed off
stay hungry stay foolish
and I've always wished that for myself
and now as you graduate to begin anew
I wish that for you
stay hungry stay foolish
thank you all very much
[Applause]
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
more incredible Steve Jobs motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I don't blame
them and it's really tough and it
consumes your life I mean if you're if
you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's been done but